Years ago I had a boyfriend tell me
And because I was an insecure idiot who was desperately afraid of losing him
I said
Sure.
The problem with open relationships, I've found, is that unless both of you
actually want to be in one and are great at honest and constructive communication
Dope okay, here are the rules:
Sex with anyone we want?  Ok.  Yeah.  Ok.  Ok.
Secrecy?  Ok!  Yeah.  No, Secrecy is cool.
Unless, I want to hear about
the people you're having sex with.
(explosion)
I should have spoken up in that moment and told him that I believe in monogamy.
And I don't think I can make an open relationship work.
Instead I decided to silently deal with the jealousy and the bitterness
that came with knowing my partner was having sex with someone else.
And it was my own fault for not even saying that I wasn't comfortable with it.
So do open relationships work?
In the one experience where I didn't want to do it and I sucked it up and tried anyway
Uh, no.
But I don't know many people who have had open relationships that have been successful
because for the most part, human beings tend to get jealous.
You look so cute and fluffly.
You've been hanging out with Congress a lot lately.
Uh.  Yeah.
Mhmmm.
Mhm.
However I do believe that there are people out there in the world who prefer open relationships.
And if those people found each other and could make rules that they agreed on
and were honest and loving
I think it could work.
I gotta be honest.  I want an open relationship.
(gasps)
I want an open relationship!
We found a love that works for us!
But for me, it's monogamy.
I don't have time for more than one boyfriend.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Lookin' real fine baby!
Hey boy!  Give me your dick!
(gasps)
I said give me yo dick.  Right now.
No.  Anything but my dick!